France 24 en español sigue creciendo la
señal de televisión de Flash 24 en
español llega a 20 países de las
Américas desde Estados Unidos hasta
Argentina a través de 82 operadores de
cable desde 2021 otros 3 millones de
hogares nos ven para llegar a un total
de más de 17 millones que reciben
nuestra señal sumados a otros 12
millones de hogares en difusión parcial
en México France 24 en español reúne
cada semana cerca de tres millones de
telespectadores en Colombia México y
Argentina y su notoriedad no deja de
crecer el canal ha crecido
exponencialmente desde su lanzamiento en
2017 entre enero y Julio de 2022 France
24 en español registra una audiencia
digital 8 veces superior a la de 2017
estamos en YouTube Facebook
Instagram nuestros vídeos registraron
151 millones de visualizaciones entre
enero y Julio de 2022 es decir más del
89% frente al de 2021 en el mismo
periodo a nuestras audiencias gracias
por su fidelidad